and in january
um of 2005 i walked into my team and i
said we are going to make
um and i it wasn't a documentary at that
stage or a movie or i didn't know what
it was we're going to make something
that will change the world and they
thought i was mad
well and i said isn't there some saying
about like it takes someone with like
say someone crazy or mad to change the
world they have to actually believe it's
possible
totally which is
which is the secret you know
and so that was how
it all began and uh and you know we were
really practicing the secret while
making the secret and so we became very
very aware
you know i was very aware of signs of
messages of hearing things of being
guided but everything we needed was just
put in front of us absolutely everything
what were the signs like what were the
things happening that made you go green
light green light green light here we go
okay so one one example is
we came to the united states to film
teachers
we had no teachers lined up to film
absolutely none whatsoever
we
we could reach teachers so easily like
it was just crazy
and they would all just say yes but one
of the teachers was jack canfield and he
was in aspen at the time and so we went
to us but he agree he agreed to be
filmed and he asked me to do a
presentation when i got there and we'd
made a big trailer and
there were something like 60 teachers
in that room
that i presented and ja when i presented
the secret and what it was going to do
and jack said
who wants to be in this documentary
put your hand up
they've all put their hand up and so in
addition to that we had been trying to
get in touch with bob proctor
through his people
and
and then when we were in aspen finally
my researcher was in touch with his
personal assistant and she said look
where are you at the moment and
and it was my sister actually who was
helping me and she's
and she said we're in aspen
and and
um bob's assistant said oh my god he's
in aspen he said aspirin yeah i see the
said
and so the moment she told him he came
over to us in 30 minutes because he knew
it was meant to be and they all knew
like
they all just knew that something
incredible was happening
and even the way we released it like i'd
had in my mind that because i had a
production company that was uh that made
content for television and so in my mind
this was going to be released on
television through networks around the
world in a 24-hour period that was the
way that i saw it that it would be
released globally basically at the same
time and so i had all of these networks
all interested and then there was this
extraordinary thing they all just
dropped out
like one by one by one by one
and so
i knew
that
this was not the way it was meant to go
and so i just opened myself to the
possibility of it going out differently
we spoke to some film companies they
just wanted to buy it and
you know buy it out completely and i i
wouldn't do it and and so then
eventually what happened was um i saw
an advertisement on the internet you've
kind of got to imagine a time that was
so different from now but i saw this
british airways commercial on the
internet
and i was like that's it
we released this on the internet now
nothing no movie had ever been released
on the internet and i called i called to
see our my ceo and i said we release it
on the internet it will be go around the
world in 24 hours and he said oh that
might be one way that you release it but
you can't release it that way entirely
well do you know my ceo
happened to be
happened to be
amazing at technology he worked with a
company that just happened to be two
streets from my office who
who put out that british airways
commercial in melbourne in australia
and
he worked with them and created the
technology for the secret to go out
um on the internet so it was the first
first um film that had gone out on the
internet and within one hour of it going
out i knew that was it like i just
sat back and it didn't matter what
happened from there it was out in the
world and that was all that mattered to
me but what's special about that story
is that it's really easy
to
see the signs when it's positive
but it's hard i feel like to accept the
signs when they're negative
and so
as you were being
you know
left to dry with the networks about
putting it out on television
i think that that that to me is the most
was a striking part about the story is
that you go okay
well we're not going to do it that way
but that that that might be the point
and i'm curious how you got to the point
where you could re where you allowed the
signs both positive and negative to
equal in
um
volume because that would be the point
in time where you know my older self
where i'm so used to forcing i would
push through and i'd be like well let's
call somebody else and let's figure this
out give me the phone send me an e i'll
send an email let's go there
and i would push through it and that's
like so can you explain how you got to
that point and how you then and how you
also stay in alignment so that you don't
force things that aren't because there's
a you have to put effort into things but
there's a difference between effort and
forcing to the point where you're
getting enough signs that it's kind of
turning into a wall yeah that's true
um
i just knew from the secret
that everything was happening for me
and that also meant that if there was a
block
don't push against it if there is a
block
and that is something doesn't come
through straight away stop
stop and for example like i'll give you
an example
we filmed
a teacher
that
um
i wasn't
100
sure about when we filmed that teacher
but there was a technical problem all
through it and that was unusable footage
you know and so i knew
i knew that that person was not meant to
be in it then there were other teachers
that we contacted who didn't respond
really well known ones for example who
didn't respond
and um and i knew they were not meant to
be in it i knew
i knew that whatever we needed would be
given to us and if there was a block
i would not push against it and as you
say actually it's very different from
what i used to be because i used to be
oh i will fix this i will do this i will
get it done and and look for another way
but instead i would stop and i would
wait to see what was going to be shown
to me and this is living this secret